the earliest tools for roasting coffee
beans were pans you would hold over hot
coals or an open fire but today coffee
roasting is a far more sophisticated
process using large often fully
automated machines with built-in gas
burners that he'd air to roast the beans
this coffee roaster is both programmable
and manually adjustable by touch panel
the roast Master can tailor the
temperature and roasting time to
influence flavor acidity and other
characteristics of coffee
to shape the rose chamber workers feed a
sheet of stainless steel through a sheet
metal roll
the rose chamber is the drum in which
the beans roast by convection Heat
[Music]
the next step is to weld the rolled
sheet into a cylinder
then workers grind and polish the welds
until they're flat smooth and shiny
another worker makes the cooling tray in
a similar way but with a support band
welded to the top the cooling tray is
the drum into which the hot beans drop
when they exit the rose chamber stirring
arms circulate the beans as a fan draws
air through the tray to cool the hot
beans
certain parts of the roaster are cut
from a stainless steel sheet stain
stainless steel is the ideal material
not only because it's stylish but also
because it's durable and corrosion
resistant
this computer guided laser cutter is
slicing out a safety component called
the heat shield
which prevents the roast master from
accidentally touching a hot surface
the heat shield like many other parts
cut from stainless steel sheets has to
be formed to a very precise shape
a worker bends angles and curves into
the metal with a press brake
[Music]
another component the Trier lets you
draw a sample of beans during roasting
a Craftsman constructs the dryer by
welding various smaller parts to a piece
of stainless steel tube
then meticulously grinding and polishing
the welds until they're smooth
[Music]
pressure water jet cutter also Cuts
parts from stainless steel sheets
this component is one of six flights
which is part of the paddle that lifts
and mixes the beans inside the rose
chamber so that they roast evenly
to form the flights to the required
shape a worker curves them one at a time
in a press
[Music]
next the welder places all the paddle
components into a specialized fixture
which positions them correctly
first he aligns the spokes to the paddle
shaft then he welds the parts in place
the flights clamps them securely and
welds them on
the combination of inner and outer
flights lifts the beans into the airflow
ensuring the beans roast evenly
a custom design grinding machine hones
the flights to produce a small clearance
of around a tenth of an inch between the
edge of the paddle and the wall of the
Rose chamber
this design ensures the paddle is wide
enough to pick up every last Coffee Bean
without touching the wall while rotating
once they install the paddle a worker
closes up the rose chamber with a face
plate
alignment pins ensure the face plate is
properly positioned
paddle shaft protrudes through a bearing
in the face plate
the assembly team uses a hoist to lift
the heavy chamber and position it on top
of the coffee roaster stainless steel
support frame
they install the heat shield that was
cut by the laser cutter and bent to
shape in the press brake
[Music]
on top the assembly team mounts The
Machine's funnel-shaped Hopper the
hopper feeds the unroasted coffee beans
to the Rose chamber below
the Hopper's lid has a tube which
connects to a vacuum system that draws
the coffee beans up through a plastic
hose
[Music]
on the front of the roasting chamber an
assembler hangs a hinged discharge door
that has a viewing window
plugs in a sensor that measures the
temperature of the beams in the roasting
chamber and sends that information to
the machine's computer
this coffee roasting machine has three
additional temperature sensors that send
data to the computer these sensors
measure the temperature of the air
entering and exiting the rose chamber
and the temperature of the Clean Air
exhausting from the machine after the
burner incinerates the smoke generated
by The Roasting process
workers continue assembly by installing
the cooling tray beneath the discharge
door of the roasting chamber
cooling tray sits on a support frame
which contains a motor that turns the
stirring arms inside the tray
at the back of the machine a worker
installs the Tray's cooling fan and the
motor that drives it
s cage measures the pressure of the air
that mixes with the gas going into the
machine's burner
[Music]
next they installed the circulation fan
the fan is designed to withstand high
heat and move air efficiently throughout
the coffee roaster
the bottom end of this stainless steel
tube connects to a vacuum motor
the top end connects to the tube
protruding from the feed Hopper's lid
to fill the roasting chamber the vacuum
motor sucks the raw green coffee beans
up into the hopper
which drops the beans into the chamber
whereas they roast their papery skin
called the chaff breaks off
this separating device known as a
cyclone connects to the circulation fan
the fan blows hot air returning from The
Roasting chamber into this Cyclone at
high velocity the air circulates in a
downward spiral past the burner at the
base of the Cyclone incinerating the
smoke
this also draws the chaff out of the air
into a barrel
nozzles spray water on the chaff to
prevent it from Catching Fire which is a
common Hazard with traditional coffee
roasters
regulation fan then forces the clean hot
air up and out the top of the Cyclone
through this s-shaped insulated air duct
back into the roasting chamber
[Music]
a technician in the Factory's electrical
department assembles The Machine's
control panel
among other components the circuitry
runs control systems and the machine's
six electric motors which operate moving
Parts such as the beam drawing vacuum
motor the circulation fan the cooling
tray fan The Roasting chamber paddle and
cooling tray stirring arms
foreign
workers then install the control panel
in a cabinet on the side of the machine
they connect all the wires
[Music]
they mount the machine's computer
adjacent to the control panel cabinet
next a worker assembles the cooling tray
system a motor under the tray drives the
stirring arms
the hot roasted coffee beans sit on top
of the stainless steel screen the
cooling fan pulls ambient air through
the beans down through the openings of
the screen then out an exhaust pipe to
the outdoors
[Music]
the stirring arms move the beans around
so that they cool quickly and evenly
which prevents the beans from continuing
to roast
[Music]
the factory runs every finished coffee
roaster through multiple test roasts
after heating the rose chamber to a
specific temperature the operator uses
the touchscreen to release the beans
into the chamber the hot air travels
from the Cyclone to the Rose chamber
then through a return pipe back to the
Cyclone where it's cleaned and sent back
to the chamber
[Music]
to know when to manually end the row
cycle the operator views smells and
listens to the beans that's because
coffee beans make crackling noises as
they expand and shed their chaff
the machine can also be set to end the
row cycle automatically when the beans
reach their target temperature a
trapdoor opens to draw in ambient air
this cooler air pushes smoke in the
roasting chamber up to the Cyclone for
incineration
the computer can automatically open the
rose Chambers discharge door or the
operator can do so manually as soon as
the roasted coffee beans drop into the
cooling tray the stirring arms and
cooling fan automatically start up if
the beans are perfectly roasted the
machine is ready to be shipped to a
coffee roasting business